[Music]
[Applause]
well hello beloved friends thank you so
much for joining us today for this
question and answer program I'd like to
know this is a program where you can
contribute to our ministry by sending us
your questions there are many many
questions that people have concerning
the scriptures you can send us any
question that you have on the Bible
we'll do the research we'll try to find
an answer sometimes there is no
information that we can use to answer
your question and we will honestly tell
you so I want to emphasize that uh your
question might not be answered in the
next program because because we've
received many many questions we put them
in order and then answer them in the
order in which we receive them so keep
on sending us your questions we collect
them and answer them as they come in let
me give you the electronic address where
you can get in touch with us with your
questions it'll be on your screen TVM
tv.org once again tvsm tv.org we'd be
delighted to receive your questions I
have with me a very good friend fellow
worker fellow laborer uh Pastor David
Salazar he is in charge of our Spanish
programming here at Secrets unsealed
among many many other things he's been
making contacts to try and get our
programs on cable television in Spanish
in different countries Chile uh in Peru
and other places and so he uh does a lot
of work to try and get exposure for our
ministry thank you thank you for being
with us pastor Pastor it's always a
privilege and an honor to serve with you
and to share from the word of God these
answers to the questions that are
friends send it's a pleasure praise the
Lord okay uh before we begin uh to
answer the questions we want to do what
we always do amen that is pray to ask
that the spirit who inspired the
scriptures will be with us to explain
them through US amen would you please
pray absolutely Pastor let's pray our
gracious Heavenly Father we are so
delighted and we thank you for giving us
the opportunity to come to your throne
of grace and to um ask of you that gift
that you have promised to for us to be
received if we ask in faith and we ask
Lord right now that you will send the
Holy Spirit to help us understand to
able to explain to share to speak the
words that may come from you so that
people those that are watching or
friends May draw closer to you and may
see the scriptures as the uh the truth
truth and as the answer to their
questions I pray that you will now speak
through us and be with us and I pray
this in jesus' name amen amen amen thank
you Pastor we have some uh very good
questions today yes and uh I'll read the
first one and then uh I'll give you the
opportunity to provide any wisdom that
you might have based on your study thank
you uh this comes from
Alex and there's no reference to a
location please remember to place
where you're sending the question from
it helps us understand the reach of
Secrets unsealed and some TV uh this is
the question in the
lineage they list Joseph as a descendant
of King David however Jesus was born of
Mary and God Mary would be his mother
God be his father not Joseph this has
always confused me do you have any
insight on this uh so what can we say
about Jesus uh not coming from the
lineage of Joseph because Joseph was not
his father uh and uh and yet giving
Christ the right to the throne uh being
from the tribe of Judah well pastor this
is uh a good question obviously and we
thank Alex for sending this question he
seems to have studied the scriptures and
we have two genealogies in both or in
two Gospels Matthew chapter 1 and then
in Luke chapter 3 and this uh you know
for example in in Matthew chapter 1 as
we go through the genealogy of of of
Christ um well it starts by saying in
verse one the book of the generation of
Jesus Christ the son of David the son of
Abraham so Matthew the first verse
specifies and declares that Jesus is the
son of go uh son of d David the son of
Abraham so that he states that he has a
lineage coming from the time of Abraham
all the way through uh David of course
and then all the way to when he was born
and at the very end of that genealogy uh
we know that in verse uh 16 he says and
Jacob speaking of who that you know he
was the father of Joseph he says and
Jacob beg Joseph the husband of Mary of
whom was born Jesus who is called Christ
and then he specifies that 14
Generations from Abraham to David and
from David to Jesus 14 generations and
so um when we look at this genealogy we
may say well like he's asking the
question you know well it seems that
genology points out to Joseph being the
one that is of you know the Juda Juda
judaic uh tribe and so he's the one
descended from from David what about
Jesus he was born of Mary obviously
Jesus was not the son of Joseph and so
that could create this this this this
situation this confusion but be before
you know maybe expanding more on that we
have to understand that the genealogy um
points out that Mary
was the wife of Joseph and just by
marriage just by that fact that she
married into his family she becomes part
of that genealogy as well they become
part of that so Matthew declares that as
a evidence enough evidence that he's a
son of David just for the fact that even
if Mary let's assume that Mary was not
of the lineage of Judah she was you know
part of it now the argument also that we
have to make is that both Mary and
Joseph both had to go to the city of
David to Bethlehem when there was a
census so when that when the you know
Caesar made that you know that census
for the whole Kingdom everybody had to
go to the place of birth and that
included both men and females so in that
sense we can see that there's to me
that's enough evidence that she was of
the lineage of David and without having
necessarily having to have spell it out
in the lineage as we just read and so
there's an argument I've heard some
people say that the look genealogy which
diers a little bit from the genealogy of
Matthew it's actually the the lineage of
Mary not of Joseph
but uh that is there is not absolutely
you know evidence to say that's 100%
accurate but I believe that this is a
very plausible scenario and explains why
Mary is also the lineage of King David
yeah you know it's interesting that
Romans chapter 1 MH in verse
three uh says something very
interesting it says concerning his son
Jesus Christ Our Lord mhm who was born
of the seed of DAV David according to
the flesh yes so Jesus was of the seed
of David according to the flesh he
didn't get that from Joseph right
because he did not have the Flesh of
Joseph exactly he had the Flesh of Mary
and so we know that Mary is involved
because he is the son of David through
Mary in other words and um you know and
then you look at um there's several
places here notice uh Matthew chap 1: 20
yeah it tells us that Joseph was also of
the lineage of David yeah because it
says in verse 20 but while he thought
about these things behold an angel of
the Lord appeared to him that is to
Joseph in a dream saying Joseph son of
David do not be afraid so both Mary was
uh of the lineage of David and Joseph
was of the lineage of Mary as well uh
Ellen White wrote In the book a call to
stand apart I think that's a devotional
book page five mhm Angels attended
Joseph and Mary as they journeyed from
their home in Nazareth to the city of
David the decree of Imperial Rome for
the enrollment of the peoples of her
vast Dominion has extended to the
Dwellers among the Hills of Galilee as
in Old Time Cyrus was called to the
throne of the world's Empire that he
might set free the captives of the Lord
so Caesar Augustus is made the agent for
the Fulfillment of God's purpose in
bringing the mother of Jesus to
Bethlehem she is of the lineage of David
and the son of David must be born in
David's City right so both Joseph and
Mary were of the lineage of of David and
therefore uh Jesus had a right to the
throne from father and from mother amen
because David was of the tribe of Judah
and Jesus was also of the tribe of Judah
amen I think that's very clear from spir
prophecy that supports this concept that
you know Mary had to be you know be
brought into even though her condition
she was already expecting you know she
couldn't avoid that and the Lord used
that adict from Caesar to bring her uh
to her you know place of birth or her
lineage which is the House of David
bethleem and he had to be born in
Bethlehem yes indeed according to Bible
prophecy absolutely okay so so what's
the next the next question is a long one
yes make a it probably would be a good
idea to read the entire okay uh question
because it it provides several different
nuances I will answer I will read the
question it says this from Maas by the
way Maas we don't know where the
location but we pray that he will um uh
continue be in contact with us and let
us know where he's from I hope this
email finds you well I am reaching out
to seek your wisdom and guidance on a
matter that pertains to both marriage
and parenting
with a focus on aligning our decision
with Biblical principles as I prepare
for marriage I have been reflecting on
the responsibilities and roles outlined
for spouses and parents in both the
Bible and the spirit of Prophecy one
question that Waits heavily on my heart
is regarding the involvement of a
married woman in work where she's
employed to earn a living while also
fulfilling her duties as a parent
specifically I am pondering whether it
is in harmony with the Bible and spirit
prophecy for a married woman to entrust
the care of her child to a house
assistant while both parents are
employees of a government or private
institution in the context of an
scenario as government employees with
regular working hours I wonder if it is
appropriate to consider asking my future
wife to resign from her government
position to prioritize her role in
parenting the spirit prophecy says that
that the God-fearing character of the
four Hebrew boys Daniel and his friends
was a result of the good parenting that
they received at the feet of their
mothers I want my children to grow up to
be like these Hebrew boys additionally I
seek Clarity on whether it is God's
intention for wives to solely focus on
taking care of the children without
engaging in any other form of employment
whether it be public or self-employment
is it in harmony with God's will for a
wife to contribute to the family income
while ensuring that her commitment to
Parenting remains
uncompromised would pursuing a
self-employed economic activity be more
conductive to fulfilling both roles
effectively furthermore I am concerned
about the potential impact on our
children's spiritual well-being if my
future wife continues in her employment
given the demanding hours that may limit
her ability for parenting
responsibilities is it advice ible in
such circumstances for her to prioritize
her role as a mother and consider
resigning from her job to safeguard or
children's salvation your insights and
Counsel on these matters will be greatly
appreciated as my future spouse and I
seek to build a marriage and family that
aligns with God's will thank you for
your time and consideration I eagerly
wait your response blessing
Maas wow well this this question
involves many many different families I
mean this isn't unique to him him mhm
it's a struggle with with many parents
in the workplace these days yes uh so
you know what could we uh tell this dear
brother uh you know he obviously cannot
force his wife to see his point of view
but he can certainly try to persuade
absolutely Pastor I think that is
important to um to remember I suppose
that if they are both and I'm I'm glad
from what he's saying this seems to me
that he and his future wife are both
trying to do what's best for them um I
think that is important for them to uh
recognize or remember that the Bible
speaks of the role of being a mother as
a a role that is perhaps above
everything else Spirit prophecy confirms
that uh actually I have you know a
couple of quotes from Spirit prophecy in
ad home page
240 and then I have page 231 that
mentions that there is really no higher
role no higher service Minister Ministry
than being a mother a good idea to read
that yeah I'll read that for them
because it's probably important that we
go into that it says in the sphere of a
mother may be humble but her influence
United with the fathers is an abiding as
eternity next to God the mother's power
for good is a strongest known on Earth
so here she's portraying that the
influence the power of a mother next to
the Lord is the strongest on Earth then
she also mentions in the uh page
231 the following the mother is Queen of
her household she has in her power the
molding of her children's character that
they may be fitted for the higher
Immortal Life an angel could not ask for
a higher mission for in doing this work
she's doing service for God so we have
just briefly two you know short quotes
there that mention how much of
importance how important how uh high is
that calling of being a mother and so if
she considers being a mother as the most
important career goal or most important
role she can perform if it comes down to
working for the government or working
for institution or what not versus being
a mother I think that the answer from
the Bible and from SP is very clear
motherhood should be first should be
most
important just to give you a personal
experience you know my my wife she's a
very intelligent and highly educated
woman and um we had talked about this
same thing you know and she's she's uh
she's in the medical field and so when
she decided or when we found out she was
going to be a mother the you know for
her at the beginning was not you know
like such easy decision like leave my
career leave my work and emphasize
myself fully into the children uh it was
not something that you know I I wanted
her to do that and I but I I encourage
her to greet and to you know follow what
the Lord will share with her and so she
thought about it she prayed about it and
she decided it was best for her to
sacrifice her career or her work for the
children sometimes that was not an easy
decision sometimes it was Temptation
people that you know uh colleagues of
her friends of her will kind of uh sort
of sometimes even look down to the fact
that she chose that decision but as as
time has proven itself you know she now
re realizes that it was the best
decision ever you know raising the
children raising the girls in the fear
of God and and molding their characters
it really is no higher Duty and she
feels so much more fulfilled in having
done that than perhaps continueing her
education and you know getting degrees
and doctorates and so forth and so on so
I think that in our experience we have
seen that this is so important and and
finally just to add to this thing you
know is is it is it you know is being a
mother preventing someone from having a
self supporting you know thing to do to
earn some income well this Spirit of
Prophecy and the Bible speaks of for
example The Virtuous Woman she actually
has the ability to to do things you know
and to bring extra income from her
resources and her influence in the home
so doesn't one thing does not prevent
the other I believe that she can be
reful if she has the skills nowadays you
can maybe do trainings from online
there's many ways you can do it you know
share the knowledge through ways that
you can stay at home and yet earn some
income as well so I also have a couple
of personal experiences uh my mother uh
was a nurse mhm and between her and my
dad they made their decisions that uh
she was going to stay at home it wasn't
forced on her yeah but she she realized
the importance of taking care of the
children right and so she was a
stay-at-home mom and she never actually
until we were all gone from the home did
she ever actually serve as an at- home
nurse right um and you know I like to
think that uh us four kids I have three
sisters plus myself that we didn't turn
out too bad because mainly of the
influence of our mother none of us are
drug addicts we're not drunks you know
we're um we attend church uh we love the
Lord uh you know and my mom never
considered it a sacrifice yeah to not
make money uh and stay at home with the
kids um Jesus in the uh when he comes
he's not going to ask us how big of a
house did you have yeah you know how
much money did you have in the bank
right or what kind of car did you drive
you know some people say well we can't
make ends meet just with one salary that
might be difficult but by exercising
sound stewardship that's right uh it's
it's very uh possible to uh to abide by
a budget and to stay at home and serve
the kids another example my wife my wife
uh worked as a conference secretary she
was secretary to the youth and
Pathfinder Department both in New Jersey
for six years and in the Texico
conference for four and a half years she
was my secretary because I was a
departmental director and she worked
but at 3:00 in the afternoon when the
kids got out of school mhm she went
picked them up and went home and spent
time with the kids while they were at
school you know that she worked but
after they got back from school she was
at home with the kids and we love to
take vacations together you know we uh
we particularly enjoyed the camp meeting
at uh New Jersey camp meeting you know
there was one week of English camp
meeting one week of Spanish camp meeting
and the kids you know Steve and Jen ER
they were out trying to get Turtles out
of the lake and even one year they they
were trying to sell the turtles to the
people who came to the camp uh but they
still remember yeah those wonderful days
when we traveled together went to camp
meeting we went to Pathfinder camper we
went to Anor uh we went to different
churches uh you know and our
vacations there's something special
about Mom yeah staying at home with the
kids yeah uh the influence of somebody
who takes care of the kids is not the
same as the mother taking care of the
kids the biological mother the husband
should not force the wife but they
should pray together they should reflect
together they should look at the pros
and cons and then they should make the
priority number one in their decision
amen the thing is I I believe the enemy
is trying to
truly break the idea that the role of a
mother it's it's as you know as
important as the Bible portrays it to be
you know a lot of the influence from the
world as you mentioned Pastor you know
we want to have two salaries usually
mainly to be able to progress in our
financial world in in grow growing our
our our income in growing and buying
more things but at the light of the word
of God the biggest treasure the biggest
gift we have is as parents is of course
the children and um the role of of being
a provider for the husband to truly be
you know a hard worker dedicated honest
uh you know that is important for him to
do and at the same time for the mother
if she needs to dedicate time for the
children uh there is a blessing that God
will you know Grant to those that follow
his steps and by faith sometimes might
might say well there's no way I can
survive in one salary or or with you
know this have the income but as you
mentioned I believe that faith has to be
exercised and if if you can have the
ability to make some extra income the
mother uh while the kids are in school
but while they're babies is impossible
you know but God will provide a way and
and so I believe that God will reward
the faithfulness of mothers and fathers
in this in this experience and I'm so
thankful that he and his future wife are
deciding Maas to follow the lord many
couples today are not thinking this way
they're not even considering you know
they married and they they AG one are
thinking on their own careers their own
you know you know path to become wealthy
without thinking that family that that
bound that you have you know that you
experience you had it's most important
especially as we're approaching the end
of days and and we really need families
that portray a character of God and a
love for the Lord amen well let me just
share a little tidbit about Pastor salad
he hasn't asked me
permission I haven't asked him for
permission to say this but anyway um he
is a
contractor you know and construction
these days is a big business he could be
making two or three times what he makes
here at Secrets unsealed yeah uh but uh
he chose to come and serve here he was
serving as a pastor by the way in the
Florida conference uh I was able to
preach in his church and in spite of
everything he decided to come here and
work at Secrets unsealed some TV and his
wife doesn't work you know she might
work one day a week or something but she
doesn't uh work work outside the home
and um I don't see him running around in
tattered clothes or starving to death
praise the Lord uh and he has two
wonderful daughters I can vouch for that
and a wonderful wife just a fantastic
family so uh I hope that our discussion
and our experiences will be helpful uh
to Kevin as he contemplates uh you know
uh getting Matias uh yeah uh contemp
getting married and forming a home where
Jesus is the constant guest and where
the kids grow up knowing the Lord and
obeying the Lord because they love him
amen amen Pastor praise the lord well
our time is just about up uh we trust
that uh what we discussed today will be
useful in your personal walk and your
decisions in life may the Lord bless you
and keep you in his care and please
don't forget to support us through your
prayers and through your financial
donations hope to see you next time i'
like I'd like to know
[Music]